[Music]
i'm keith olbermann in this is the
resistance it went by so quickly and in
such a cacophony of five interviewees
all on at the same time that its
importance seemed to go right past
everybody maybe even past the man who
was saying it quoting there is serious
belief in the FBI in the congressional
committees in the House and the Senate
that there is an active cover-up going
on involving trying to keep
investigators from finding out what
happened in terms of the Trump campaign
Trump associates near the top of the
campaign and what happened in their
associations with Russians and that
there is an active cover-up going on one
of the things that the congressional
committees are very concerned about as
is the FBI is that they don't have the
resources to conduct a proper
investigation and the White House is
taking advantage of it an active White
House cover-up to keep the FBI and
Congress from finding out what the
connections between all the trumps men
and Russia really mean it is a startling
conclusion it was attributed by the CNN
guests to FBI and Capitol Hill sources
and it was said by who Carl Bernstein
being dead right about Watergate 44 45
and 46 years ago does not mean he is
automatically right about Trump and
Russia but it does mean Carl Bernstein's
reporting gets a faster and more durable
benefit of the doubt than anybody else's
and while Bernstein underscored that
there yet may prove to be nothing to the
Trump Russia links the unalterable fact
of history is that Richard Nixon was
forced from office not by the Watergate
break-in but by the Watergate cover-up
people went to jail during the infamous
Teapot Dome scandal not because of the
oil but because of the cover-up they got
big tobacco because of the cover-up
iran-contra cover-up the Dreyfus Affair
cover-up even Bill Clinton was impeached
not based on what he did or didn't do
but because of the cover-up
and Bernstein now says FBI on Capitol
Hill sources believe there is an active
cover-up being undertaken right now by
the Trump administration if that's true
the cover-up by itself might be
impeachable even if there is no Russian
smoking gun or if it is never produced
well what would it look like what would
the
signs of a cover-up B I mean apart from
the nuclear detonation sized obvious
things like the Jeff Sessions recusal or
the self defense tracing of congressman
Devin you haven't heard from me lately
have you newness well how about all the
principles backing away from one another
like oh the new head of the CIA branding
WikiLeaks a quote non-state hostile
intelligence service often abetted by
state actors like Russia or like
WikiLeaks tweeting Trump's breach of
promise over the release of his tax
returns is even more gratuitous than
Clinton concealing her goldman sachs
transcripts or the Justice Department
reportedly seeking to charge Julian
Assange and even perhaps trying to pry
him from his ID hole at the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London where he is visited by
Nigel Farage and Pamela Anderson
separately please God
or maybe Vladimir Putin's primary TV
mouthpiece Dmitry Kiselyov telling his
Russian viewing audience quote Trump is
more impulsive and unpredictable than
Kim jong-un and quoting him again more
dangerous or the younger of the [ __ ]
twins Eric telling a British newspaper
of the missile strike in Syria quote if
there was anything that Syria did it was
to validate the fact that there is no
Russia tie or most recently Trump
himself telling The Associated Press
that in 2016 WikiLeaks came out never
heard of WikiLeaks never heard of it
except that on December 2nd 2010 asked
by this Fox clown you had nothing to do
with WikiLeaks Trump said no but I think
it's disgraceful I think there should be
like death penalty or something
so Trump denounces WikiLeaks and
WikiLeaks denounces Trump and the Trump
Justice Department threatens to arrest
Assange and the Russians denounce Trump
as more dangerous than Kim jong-un and
Eric Trump makes it look like Daddy
fired 59 missiles just to show he's not
a Russian marionette and then Trump
never heard of WikiLeaks until last year
except he did in 2010 boys do not
everybody try to run out of the room at
the same moment you'll all get crushed
trying to get through the exit coverup
there are other slightly more subtle
signs of a cover-up notice another odd
story that turned up on CNN quoting it
the FBI gathered intelligence last
summer that suggests Russian operatives
tried to use
Trump advisors including Carter page to
infiltrate the Trump campaign according
to US officials the new information adds
to the emerging picture of how the
Russians tried to influence the 2016
election not only through email hacks
and propaganda but also by trying to
infiltrate the Trump or bit see what
they're doing there
Carter page is no longer a trump foreign
policy advisor the second one Trump ever
mentioned he's no longer as has been
theorised an alleged courier carrying a
reported audio tape of Trump to Vladimir
Putin and offered to swap Russian
friendly policy changes in exchange for
the election role hacking by the
Russians so Steve Bannon could micro
target American voters he's no longer a
possible traitor now Carter Paige is the
victim US officials that it presumably
be current US officials you know like
Trump or somebody appointed by Trump and
there aren't that many yet suggesting
the Russians tried to infiltrate the
Trump campaign by using people too dumb
to realize it like Carter page and this
Carter page becomes not a conspirator
but the injured party the way if Trump
or his buddies are indeed on tape
because they happen to be talking
erosions that foreign intelligence
services were spying on Trump and the
Trump hats are not disloyal monsters
willing to sell out this nation they
were the victims of wiretap and Barack
Obama and Susan Rice and maybe the devil
himself Karl Bernstein's comments last
Friday about serious belief at the FBI
and the House and Senate Intel
committees that Trump is at this moment
perpetrating an active cover-up of his
people's ties to Russia underscore the
necessity of an independent prosecutor a
necessity so important the Democratic
candidates for the house next year ought
to run on it and pin down their
Republican opponents on it by waving the
flag and asking who is running this
country us or the goddamned Russians and
another thing about Bernstein on
Watergate I'm trying to make Paige and
Trump and whoever is next in to the
victim rather than the perpetrator early
in the Watergate cover-up Richard Nixon
tried to make it look like the whole
thing was John Dean's idea that Nixon
was the victim
that there was a witch-hunt McCarthyism
communists we ran out of gas we've got a
flat tire we didn't have change for cab
fare
we lost our tuxes at the cleaners we
locked their keys in their car an old
friend came in from out of town there
was an earthquake a terrible flood
locust it wasn't our fault we swear to
God it sure looks like a cover-up resist
peace